the look inside the newest professional
sports venue in the country and then
it's game-changing design climate pledge
arena just opened in seattle my hometown
and it's home to the national hockey
league's expansion team amazon paid an
estimated half a billion dollars to name
the arena but instead of putting the
company's name on it amazon decided to
raise awareness about the effects of
climate change ben tracy shows us how
the arena aims to be unlike any other in
the world
[Music]
in a swirling storm of confetti coldplay
christened seattle's new arena
[Music]
[Applause]
and the building's unusual name was just
about everywhere from above the beer bar
to the massive wall of plants lining one
of the main concourses to the very top
of the roof
and i think it will just be an amazing
place for a player to play toddle wiki
is president and ceo of the seattle
kraken able to swing it across doug
which just played its first game in its
new home what does it mean to have the
team playing in an arena called climate
pledge arena this building stands for
great hockey and great events but it
stands for something even broader which
is a major statement about our
environment the climate the climate
pledge was co-founded by amazon in 2019
and calls for businesses to reach net
zero carbon emissions by 2040. that's 10
years ahead of the paris climate accords
timeline hundreds of major corporations
have signed on and so has the arena
itself we made the pledge that this will
be zero carbon events can occur and we
don't have to feel guilty at the end of
the night that we've somehow bruised our
community in the earth but to become the
world's first net zero carbon
entertainment venue the arena will have
to operate with no fossil fuels using
100 renewable energy from solar and wind
farms this is expected to save 1.7
million pounds of planet-warming carbon
emissions every year
and this will be the first arena in the
nhl to ban single-use plastics beginning
in 2024
and everything in the building that
would have been natural gas is now all
electric rob johnson is the arena's vice
president of sustainability he brought
us up here to see some of those solar
panels but also the arena's unique roof
which if it looks a bit old-fashioned
well that's because it is
it was first built for the 1962 world's
fair in seattle alongside the iconic
space needle and the city's then
futuristic monorail it's a protected
landmark that can't be torn down
so in an epic example of recycling they
put all 44 million pounds of it on
stilts for an entire year while they dug
out a brand new arena 58 feet underneath
it you're coming back to a new building
underneath the historic roof where folks
like the beatles have played jimi
hendrix has played hometown heroes like
nirvana have played in
and now the kraken will play on what's
being billed as the greenest ice in the
nhl this was actually rain water
two weeks ago the ice is now resurfaced
with rain water collected on the roof
fitting because it was originally
designed as a tribute to a native
american rain hat
and yes even the zambonis creating all
that new ice are electric
are you feeling my guy but when it comes
to cooking without gas well that's never
been done at a venue this large how big
of a challenge is it to have no gas to
cook with
it's a huge challenge but
i hate to break into the world there's
no gas lines on a dead planet right
molly demirs is the arena's executive
chef her team is sourcing most of their
ingredients from a 300 mile radius and
nearly eliminating food waste with
smaller portions
a lot of the food here is plant-based
we're growing our own food we're curing
our own meats we are making our own
cheeses we are really looking at every
level you guys are making a lot of
promises here so how will people know
you're doing what you say you're going
to do we're going to report out on a
regular basis the carbon footprint of
our building we have to do a detailed
accounting of every potato coming for
the french fries on every t-shirt being
sold for concerts or for home cracking
or storm games we have to account for
all of those emissions and we have to
offset those annually
todd lightwiki says they won't get it
all right right away but that those big
green letters on top of the arena aren't
just promotion they're also a promise
and we hope to win every game but we
won't but we can win every day on this
issue and making sure that we live up to
the pledge we took
let's go cracking for cbs morning's ben
tracy sienna
let's go crash
[Applause]
people i'm proud to be from seattle all
right all right
who's paying for it that's what i want
to know that's a good question it is but
you know by using the roof the 22 000
pounds of steel and metal and and
reusing it you're not only recycling
that portion of it but you're saving on
carbon emissions a lot of carbon
emissions by not building i want i want
to know more about the guy or the group
or the team that held that roof up for a
year straight while they were building
underneath of it yeah that's been
creative yeah innovative role but the
game changer would be just how much of
of that arena amazon paid for or it is
an open question uh also tonight google
banter i just try we will not be
googling